let's talk about covid in China
the government spent the last three
years enforcing a super strict policy
known as zero covet
then basically overnight
China abandoned almost all of its
restrictions this was done in a sort of
convulsive political Lurch people were
not prepared for it so many hospitals
are completely under strained medical
staff under immense pressure
crematoriums are working overtime and
now it looks like it's going to get even
worse with so many people on the move of
a Lunar New Year holiday millions of
workers are expected to travel from
cities back to their rural home towns so
many people have been kept away for so
long from seeing relatives and things
like that they're expecting a very very
large migration so why did China make
this sudden u-turn on covid what could
this huge wave of infections mean for
the country and how will it affect the
rest of the world
so since the early days of the pandemic
China was living under this stringent
zero coveted policy which meant
basically that the government considered
one infection one infection too many
people with covid and their close
contacts were forced into state-run
quarantine camps cities and regions were
in and out of lockdowns and you'd get
things like an entire apartment block
being quarantined because of just one
case
domestic and international travel was
heavily restricted too
and it seems that for a long time people
generally supported this approach the
zero covered policy in China was
especially at the beginning of the
pandemic a source of national pride here
in China the official death toll at
least was very low but as the rest of
the world started to loosen restrictions
and open up the Chinese government
didn't budge
people were getting angry there were
reports of things like people being
locked inside a building during an
earthquake
another is unable to escape a burning
apartment block because of lockdown
measures something Chinese officials
denied
that fire in the city of arimchib which
is in the West Was a big moment because
it triggered public protests against
zero covid which then spread to many of
the big cities across the country
protests like this are super rare
[Music]
suddenly in early December it was all
over the government changed its policy
from an all-out war on covid to calling
it a mild disease and relaxing the rules
we saw them charging as hard as possible
in the direction of zerocovid and now
we're seeing them charged as hard as
possible in the direction of
implementation of dismantling zero
covered some people say it was the
protests that spooked the leadership
into changing course and the added
political pressure for sure but also the
economic and social costs were just
getting so high and trying to contain
the Omicron variant was like fighting a
losing battle because it's way more
infectious than the original strains but
I think the government was looking for
some sort of way out because they backed
themselves into a corner so where are we
now well covert has already ripped
through China's major cities like
Beijing and Shanghai it literally went
from me not knowing anybody who called
Corbett in China
to
everybody catching literally everybody
catching covert in a space of a few
weeks it was really surreal the problem
is there's been no consistent reporting
of data on the number of cases or deaths
and the government stopped publishing
daily figures in late December we do
have a couple of key numbers though
according to leaked reports from
government meetings China's officials
reckon that 250 million people got
covert during the first 20 days of
December that's double the population of
Japan in 20 days more recently a health
official announced that almost 60
thousand people died from covid over
five weeks and that the numbers were now
dropping Parliament
the World Health Organization has been
asking China for better data and says it
welcomes these latest figures to help
understand the situation although it
would still like to see a more detailed
breakdown
now whether or not zero covid was the
right call whether it lasted too long
those are ongoing debates but wherever
you stand on that a lot of people are
questioning why there wasn't a better
exit strategy China bought itself time
for the virus to become milder but you
would also think that in buying itself
time over those three years that it
would have made basic preparations but
what we saw when the virus restrictions
were lifted we saw a very different
picture we saw chaos and essentially
millions of people defenseless in the
face of this virus and that's where
China's vaccine program comes in for
criticism most people have had two doses
of a chinese-made vaccine but Studies
have shown they aren't quite as
effective as some of the western ones
although they still offer some
protection against severe disease and
death the bigger problem is that not
enough people have had third or fourth
doses especially the most vulnerable
the government took their foot off the
gas about over a year ago fall in terms
of getting people to do more booster
shots and so people early on who might
have been protected from earlier
versions of covid aren't getting
protection offered by newer boosters or
newer Doses and now we've got the Lunar
New Year
[Applause]
when huge numbers of people travel from
the cities to rural areas we're talking
two billion Trips Trips that many
haven't been able to make since the
pandemic started
and all that travel is expected to
create another surge of covet infections
in rural communities that are even less
prepared the healthcare capacity is
there are even weaker and the
vaccination levels in the rural areas
are also much weaker so there's a lot of
concern that this is going to do more
damage there are projections that we
could be looking at around 2 million
um dead in China by the time this has
has played out in some ways it's a
really scary picture but there's another
side to all of this the many who are
young and healthy who may have caught
the virus already especially in the
bigger cities I have to say there is
actually a lot of optimism and a lot of
positivity going forward I think people
are more relieved than anything that
they can just live normal lives and that
China will at least start to be
reconnected with the rest of the world
so what does all this mean for the rest
of the world well on the health front
there's a concern that what's happening
in China could somehow increase the risk
of a dangerous new variant emerging so
far though based on the genetic data
provided by the Chinese government at
least there's no sign of that anytime
you have spread at a massive scale it
does allow for the opportunity for the
virus to evolve that's simply a product
of the virus being replicated and spread
from person to person at a massive scale
and although it's possible that that can
happen and may have happened the
dominant streams being reported are
versions of Omicron that we already have
and so the relative risk to other
regions of the world is pretty low then
the other big question is about how all
of this affects the global economy
foreign
took a huge hit during the pandemic last
year growth dropped to its lowest level
in 40 years people lost jobs factories
shut down and many foreign companies got
nervous about investing in China because
things were so unpredictable especially
with all the stop-start lockdowns
[Music]
it's reopening the economy is expected
to pick up how quickly that'll happen is
what a lot of people are wondering hope
and the expectation on the Chinese
government's part is that once this has
rippled out later in the year you'll
have a kind of bounce back that's good
news for people in China and the
countries and industries that rely
heavily on doing business with China
there's a saying that when China sneezes
the global economy catches a cold China
is such a huge engine for powering the
global economy one example of how zero
covert affected the global economy is
that it basically choked so many of
these Global Supply chains and all of a
sudden
people were having difficulties sourcing
things as basic as a paper cup but a
side effect of China's recovery might be
that it makes Global inflation worse
than it already is as Chinese factories
and businesses get going again they'll
need to import more Commodities like oil
and iron ore that increases demand and
pushes up their price which can then
have a knock-on effect on the price of
so many other things we buy
so everything that's going on in China
right now really brings home how far
reaching the effects of the pandemic are
and it's a painful reminder that this
thing's not over yet
check out our last episode about the
protests in Iran if you want to
understand what's going on there and let
us know in the comments what other
topics you want us to explain
[Music]